we begin this morning with the world's
richest man pulling the plug on his plan
to buy one of the most influential
social media platforms elon musk
announced he's abandoning his 44 billion
dollar bid to buy twitter and take the
publicly traded company private in april
the tesla founder revealed he had
purchased nine percent of twitter stock
and began securing financing to complete
the purchase but while the
multi-billionaire now says the purchase
is off twitter is saying not so fast
michael george is here to explain where
this very public and very messy deal
stands michael good morning michelle
good morning you know breakups can be
tough and it looks like this one's
headed to court late yesterday twitter
put elon musk on notice with a statement
saying they plan to pursue legal action
to enforce the merger agreement
san francisco-based twitter has been on
a rough ride with elon musk for the last
three months with its stock price
sinking to close down five percent at
36.81
yesterday well below the 5420 musk
offered to pay to acquire the company i
also believe that he offered way too
high to begin with christopher boozy
heads bot sentinel which monitors fake
social media accounts that have become
central to musk's supposed reason for
wanting out of the twitter deal you
probably read about the
question as to whether
the number of
fake and spam users on the system is
less than five percent as twitter claims
twitter won't or can't say how many fake
accounts it hosts the reportedly a
million fake accounts get taken down
every day the fact that twitter really
can't give him that information or elon
claims that twitter is not able to give
him that information is a problem but on
wall street two months of haggling has
taken a toll that started april 4th with
twitter's stock rising more than 28
percent after musk revealed he'd
acquired nine percent of the company's
stock the price rose further on april
25th when musk agreed to buy twitter but
on may 13th twitter shares plunged 25
percent after musk tweeted the deal is
temporarily on hold the price dropped
further on may 17th with another musk
tweet the deal cannot move forward he
said until the company proves only five
percent of twitter users are fake and
advertisers when they're advertising we
want to actually advertise to human
beings additionally musk's own company
tesla became more involved in the deal
when he sold more than 8.5 billion
dollars in shares to help with his
proposed twitter purchase but then tesla
shares dropped too setting off
speculation that even the world's
richest man was in over his head
now musk did sign an agreement saying
he'd pay 1 billion if he broke off the
deal and he can certainly afford it but
right now it seems twitter is more
focused on trying to force musk to buy
the company by taking him to federal
court there's billions of dollars on the
line for the company's shareholders
nancy very interesting to watch michael
thank you